I've seen a lot of videos recently on Twitter in particular
about people wondering about voting for
in the local and and European elections that are coming up in June.
And a lot of people are asking a very similar question.
You know, in order for me to punish a particular party,
for example,
I'm gonna give them seventh or eighth or ninth preference vote in the.
On my voting sheet. So let's just say,
for example, there's 12 particular candidates in,
let's just say the European election in one particular region.
1:00 to twelve. And they're gonna go right,
well, I'm gonna give my first preference to this person I like
and this person I like and I'm gonna go all the way down
and there you go. Let's just pick Fina 4 for example,
or Fina gal. Doesn't really matter your candidate.
I'm giving you No. 12 cause I wanna punish you
for the way the government has run the country.
Well, let me just explain to you why that is absolutely wrong.
And this is again a video where I want people thinking before we got 5,
6 weeks going up before the election.
So I want people realizing,
let's own say, the consequences of their actions.
what could happen if you try to punish somebody on the voting ballot
and you. It could go horribly wrong.
So we remember the last general election
where a lot of current sitting ministers
or TDS got elected in Particular couple of the high power ones
got elected in on 4, 5th.
6th can't count. So let me explain to you as to why that happened.
Because people who tried to punish them
takes their box or put down their number on the ballot sheet.
Which means. So here's how the voting works.
We all collect a ball of ballot sheets.
We go No.. 1.
And then they take a random sample of what's left.
And out of that random sample they go to. Well,
who got No. 2?
And then we eliminate. And then we take a random sample again.
And whoever got No. 3.
So if you work on that basis by giving somebody any number vote.
Whether be first to last or anywhere in between,
there is a chance that vote will count.
So that's why it is so important
that if you really wanna punish a particular government party
or particular party. You don't put their name,
you don't put their ticket,
don't put a number anywhere near the balochies at all.
You just put who you want to vote for
number one. If you fancy a second person,
No.. 2.
But do not give a number to anybody that you're trying to punish
or that you don't want to see reelectors.
Because that number and that vote may count.
And there's a great example of this
how one particular. I won't say party,
but one particular institution of politics goes around.
I know you Won't give me your No. 1 because I know you're Afina Fall.
I know you're Afina Gale.
Give me your No. 2.
And that's how they're elected time and time and time again.
Brilliant politics.
And if we look at what's going around in politics right now,
I want you to look at how carefully look at the candidates,
some of the big government parties are running.
Look at the communities where they're looking for votes right now,
because they know you and I,
average Joe soap, average Joe voter is not gonna vote for them.
So they're scouring the land to try and votes.
Find votes from somewhere.
And that's why it is so crucial
that if you genuinely don't want to see them back in politics,
you do not put a tick,
a number or anything on the ballot sheet beside their name.
Crucial. Just vote for who you want in and nothing for who you want out.
Also, bear in mind,
do not put down, if you think one particular person has,
let's just say, room the nation
and you think he's a bullocks,
do not put bullocks in the square beside his or her name,
because it could potentially be a spoiled vote.
So if you're genuine, and if you're.
And by the way, nobody's looking at this,
that you call, so nobody will know that you call them that anyway.
So if you're genuinely serious,
and that's why I want this video to go around,
To as many people as possible.
So again, remember my line.
I don't want you to think like me,
but I just want you to think.
I want you to share as much as possible
so that everybody realizes that potentially
putting down a number in the ballot box
by somebody you want, I could actually get them in.
So we got 5, 6 weeks.
I'll do another video closer to the time.
But remember,
if you want change in politics,
we gotta change the politicians.
By putting a number, or by putting something that gonna spoil your vote.
Could potentially get the same ones back in. Again,
something to think about for today.
And have a look at this. Actually,
unbelievably,
probably won't see it,
but that bright thing out there in carry is the sun.
Hopefully a great weekend.
So hopefully, I don't care what anyone says.
All this rain is the press the hell out of everybody.
Hopefully the sunshine will make you smile for the weekend.
Have a great day. Remember the most important message of the video,
apart from sharing it so more people see it.
Do not, under any circumstances,
try to penalize somebody you want out of politics
by giving them any number on the ballot box,
or by calling them anything in their little square beside their name.
Have a fantastic day.